II that hook
excuse me our next woman to speak of
tribute Shirley MacLaine
I of course I'm going to speak directly
to Bella
[Applause]
my village step was that you two nights
ago in my bedroom opening and closing
the door I would like to have the answer
to that and ensuring the place that I
was always imagined I was and I'm the
one who's grounded now I would like I
would like to know from of mysteries
that you must appear that I have been
longing to understand most of my adult
life I know one thing you're in one hell
of a poker game with Martin's up there I
can feel it I can feel check in on check
I want you to know that sometimes I
never really told you what was deeply in
my heart because we were so busy with oh
I guess I would say or explain matters
but you were one of the few people may
be the only person I've ever met who was
always right about character you could
have sent the person's character coming
from whatever that knows an instinctual
thing was in you absolutely on the
button you were never wrong and of
course the character that you assessed
in the person usually flopped over into
their leadership their politics what
they thought was right or wrong I never
really saw you Bella as a basic feminist
I saw you as a humanist
[Applause]
I've been looking for another sign for
new day you know your your sense of how
you work with with really right-wing
conservative people always amused me
because you're you understand those
people needed more help than you I used
to get the biggest kick out of when you
would come and visit me ostensibly to
see me whenever I played in Las Vegas
and you stay for the opening number and
then you and I'm gambled Oh Bell escape
website you were what what an incredible
sense of the fullness and richness of
how to lead a life you showed me I often
wondered when we had our talks about
life after life and what maybe was out
there and he used to read me some of the
Jewish
legendary books that the soul always
returned to the body the next day and I
would argue that that meant that it was
separate and that when life seemed to
cease in the body that the souls delived
you always came from a left-brain point
of view of course very very scientific
and you had to have it proved but there
was something about the way your eyes
melted in the way your mouth sort of and
you did this a lot and I thought maybe
she really is thinking about these
things as she goes about trying to make
sense of a world that you always told me
you thought was suffering a nervous
breakdown your sense of star witness
your sense of meaning your impatience in
your temperament was always to meet a
harbinger for things that would
ultimately come to pass you were
impatient as you saw it you saw things
and other people you saw things in event
who saw things in political evolution
long before other people thought
I never told you really how much I loved
you because sometimes you thought the
dispensation of political rhetoric would
have served the moment better but i did
in ways that to me were exactly it
simplifying more of the sense of what a
real woman was to me you were a true
woman and added to that half that was a
man I will miss your tooth telling I
will miss your truth living I will miss
your truth seeking I will miss the
friendship that was based on such
honesty that it took my breath away and
I will be speaking to you in the future
I will be listening and I will be
knowing and the deepest part of me that
we've changed places now and you can
teach me hi della
[Applause]